la session de printemps des assises du
calvados
hier raymond adam été condamné à 15 ans
de prison pour avoir tué sa femme
aujourd'hui comparé c'est jean-michel
rebours accusé de tentative d'homicide
nous retrouvons élise lucet au palais de
justice de caen enfances difficiles
problèmes familiaux importants scolarité
interrompue à 23 ans jean michel rebours
compte déjà 17 condamnations sur son
casier judiciaire
le portrait des psychiatres n'est pas
plus brillant rebours étant instable un
impulsif un déséquilibré psychopathe
important un portrait accablant sur
lequel l'avocat général c'est bien sûr
appuyé tout au long de son réquisitoire
pour lui l'accusé est un homme dangereux
vaubourg quand il est contrarié fonce
sans se soucier de quoi que ce soit le
ministère public a donc requis une peine
de 10 ans de réclusion pour tentative
d'homicide
du côté de la défense maître delcourt
s'est appliqué à démontrer que jamais
jean-michel rebours on avait une
intention de renverser les policiers
qui tentaient d'empêcher sa fuite pour
lui l'accusé doit être condamnée pour
son rodéo en voiture n'est certainement
pas pour tentative d'homicide mais trop
d'un coup insiste rebours n'a rien d'un
meurtrier
il ya simplement voulu échapper à la
prison il demande donc une peine de deux
mois à deux ans
pour voies de fait sur un agent de la
force publique au bourg puis tout au
long
c'est lundi qu'une chose
c'est paniqué je ne pensais qu'à m'en
suis
pour ne pas retourner en prison les vers